in vino veritas certes mais hier le
ministre de l'agriculture n'a t-il pas
pousser le bouchon un peu loin
je crois pas que les mains sous ton
école comme les autres l'addiction à
l'alcool est dramatique et notamment
dans la jeunesse avec le binge drinking
c'est dramatique mais je n'ai jamais vu
ma connaissance
malheureusement peut-être un jeune qui
sort de boîte de nuit et qui est sous
parce qu'il a bu du côtes du rhône de du
cros hermitage en bourgogne pour la
filière viticole et de nombreux élus les
propos du ministre ne sont pas à
consommer modérément ils sont jugés
gouleyant est plein de bon sens non là
on a réagi positivement parce que c'est
une vision que l'on a
normalement le vin il ya d'alcool mais
nous on fait on promet une consommation
du vin ce plaisir c'est à dire les
arômes le goût donc l'alcool est un
élément composant du vin mais ce n'est
pas l'essentiel dans notre approche dure
je suis plutôt d'accord
le vin c'est un produit de culture pas
que d'agriculture simplement il faut par
déterré la hache de guerre
1 on se souvient des débats a joué 20
les amendements que j'avais dû prendre
l'époque donc le pam mobiliser les
associations qui vont dire voyez ça y
est c'est encore le lobby du vin qui se
manifeste et qui dans ces conditions et
c'est de dire que c'est pas de l'alcool
trop tard le mal est fait pour les
médecin addictologue voir dans le vin
une sorte d'exception culturelle qui le
distinguerait des autres alcools est une
aberration en termes de santé publique
du point de vue du foie comme du cerveau
le vent est un alcool comme un autre
avec les mêmes conséquences nocives
si on l'en concerne en trop grande
quantité et ce quelle que soit sa
qualité
en fait c'est à dire même si c'est que
ce soit du 20 ans qu mieux pomare xi les
consonnes en trop grande quantité d'eau
un impact négatif enfin les études de
l'observatoire français des drogues et
toxicomanies montre que les jeunes se
saoulent aussi avec du vin 18% des
alcoolisations ou du champagne 25%